if you do it's time now for CBS
morning's deals this week we're
highlighting three things that might
help you save time and money at the
grocery store in the kitchen and much
more all that exclusive low prices to
start shopping now scan the QR code on
your screen right now you can also visit
cbsdeals.com Rachel Rothman is executive
technical director for Good Housekeeping
Institute and she joins us right now
good morning Rachel how you doing good
morning thank you so much for having me
of course of course I think we're
missing somebody right now all right
look at you David thank you very much
this is how I shop every day you look
good doing it so let's start with this
Good Housekeeping says these are the
best reusable bags for grocery shopping
for the family this is a really
fantastic set so four reusable bags come
in here all the products you're seeing
here we test Gail knows up on the 29th
floor we are vigorously testing these
products so I have taken these with me
to the grocery store we've had testers
using it we've looked at it in the labs
and they are really durable and what is
great is that they're so versatile so
what you're seeing is after checkout you
can place things in all the different
categories and then just load it up into
your car or into the cab and it'll be
really easy for you to transport so we
have one that's insulated and for all
those frozen items you're seeing a
special place that you can spot oh right
these are all coats and insulated ones
and what's great is you just pop out
those different rods when you get home
and you can throw it into the washing
machine or they all also have velcro
right here if you detach them then you
can just use one single bag like that
you can pop out those rods too and you
can just use it as a canvas tote so we
know those plastic bands are going into
effect in a lot of places in New York
you have to pay additional money okay so
with these you're being environmentally
conscious and they're really great
reusable and 40 percent off
everybody knows I don't I'm still
grocery shopping at CVS but if you did
go to the grocery store I do think that
you could line this up because normally
when you go all your stuff is all
jumbled up in the car yeah
I think this is a good idea super clever
and like I said if you're just going
into CVS you can just grab one on its
own and it's super easy you can go get
your cough drop in your eggs
that's about my grocery shopping list
too if your friends see you in the
grocery store with this they'll never
stop making fun of you but anyway all
right it's all good I'm a rocket just
like the housekeeping may have to have a
little talk with you about your
groceries
so next up from Green Pan this is an 11
piece set 145 off so 175 dollars for all
11 pieces so anodized aluminum is going
to be really durable it's going to hold
up and then it is coated with green pan
Signature ceramic non-stick non-stick is
key it is for anybody that loves to cook
if you love to cook and these Skillets
right here you have an eight inch and a
10 inch so if you're frying those eggs
you don't even not to use oil it's going
to pop right off and it gives you that
perfect sear or really great caramelized
it's really nice looking you have a one
quarter two quart a three quarter five
quart the lids the Skillets and then you
also have the steamer right here as well
not stick for me I sold you at nonstick
that was all that's all I needed to do
it's just hard to find a good non-stick
pan yes
true what's the price how much is it
this is 175 for all of those is an
amazing gift to get for the holidays
okay and lastly Dave what do you got
what you got you love this one this is
the drop stop so there's a reason that
this is a massive hit on a shark tank so
with this it's 40 off and you're gonna
get two of them and this right here what
you're opening it goes over your your
seat belt okay and then it goes into
that area that's kind of the you know
that dark area that things always fall
into your phone your keys your lipstick
Bermuda Triangle with your car thank you
very much so 80 of accidents happen when
you take your eyes off the road for just
three seconds the LAPD has been using Us
in all of their vehicles oh really and
they saw an over 40 percent reduction in
accidents with its use in it so you know
what Rachel this would be good on a
plane have you ever dropped your cell
phone on a plane I've definitely done
that as well yes this is yeah this is
good and you can look it's it's
yeah
I would have thought this really simple
item could really be like yeah if I had
a car if I had a car I would have it on
everything over two dozen vehicles and
infinite all of them so it's able to
compress so stop
it'll stop the change as well and those
french fries it is stain resistant tell
us the price already yeah this one is
fifteen dollars for the two forty
percent off really tremendous value on
all these tested products
um great holiday gifts so thank you guys
so much for having me thank you thank
you she does work on the coolest floor
in the Hearst Tower 29. well done all
right you can check out Rachel and her
team's latest product reviews in this
month's issue of Good Housekeeping of
course we partnered with all these
companies to get the best deals you can
buy anything that you saw right now just
scan the QR code on your screen it's
simple or you can head over to
cbsdeals.com to start shopping now for
these items and so much more